Westworld season 2 episode 8 starts with
William near-death a Kate shooter turns
up and speaks in Lakota
the language spoken by ghost nation we
know that Williams daughter Emily
learned this language but William never
did despite his years of obsession with
the secrets of Westworld he never
learned to communicate with one of the
parks most mysterious groups
this shows how ghost nation and maybe
indigenous peoples generally are
overlooked and it's a reminder that
Emily knows more about Westworld than
she's letting on okay Trudeau saves
Williams life but not out of kindness
he says death is an escape from this
brutal world and William doesn't deserve
to die because a cage shooter remembers
Williams crimes like killing Maeve and
her daughter so he keeps William alive
as punishment to hurt him this idea of
death as freedom from life is similar to
Dolores as reasoning for destroying the
cradle last episode
Emily arrives to pick up her dad and
says that she also wants William to hurt
maybe she just means to hurt him
emotionally to force him to face his
mistakes fix their relationship and come
home like she asked him earlier or maybe
she'll do something worse we know
Emily's involved somehow with the delos
immortality project maybe she'll use it
to make William suffer in the Mesa Lee
looks over Maeve she had been so
powerful lately but now she is
vulnerable and broken Lee had helped
create Maeve he wrote some of her lines
at least and for most of the season he
didn't believe that hosts could be more
than their code but after seeing the
realness of Maeve's passion this season
he's realized that she deserves to be
free he apologizes for getting a shot
and tries to have her fixed
but Charlotte finds out about Mapes
power to control hosts Dolores warned
last episode that the humans would use
may have against them
so Charlotte might want to turn Maeve
into her own tool for control so Maeve
might need lee's help to escape but
throughout this episode Maeve uses her
power to see through the eyes of her
host daughter and she listens as akator
tell
his life story Akita hawky
once lived a peaceful life with his
partner Kohana this was 35 years ago
when Ford and Arnold were first starting
Westworld Arnold realized that the hosts
could become conscious and that the park
would be held for them so he programmed
Dolores to kill the hosts and Arnold
hoping to stop the park from opening
which again connects to this idea of
death being freedom from life
this was the Escalante Massacre and
Akita saw its aftermath he found
Arnold's maize toy which represents a
hosts journey to consciousness
so like Dolores Akita began his own
awakening but before he got fully woke
he was reprogrammed because Arnold's
massacre failed to stop Westworld
opening with investment from William and
Delos Ford opened the park anyway and he
made changes to the hosts are keys
peaceful life with Kahana was replaced
with the life of a brutal warrior
dehumanized bad guy for the west-world
guests to kill so for a while a key lead
goes nation warriors in season one we
saw a ghost nation attacking Confederate
US and attacking Mae but her homestead
but our key still knew that something
was wrong with his world he looked for
answers and found Logan in the desert
this connects to the end of season one
when William tied Logan to a horse to
discredit him but our key had actually
met Logan years before he and Angela
were used to convince Logan to invest so
maybe seeing Logan again reminds our key
of this other past life and Logan tells
our key that West world is an illusion
and there's a way out a door so our key
learns that this world is fake he has
lived other lives and there's a way out
so he searches further and finds the
valley this is the facility William
built 30 years ago for his plan to
record West world guest data this may be
a place where copied human minds are
stored in the latest timeline who have
seen the valley flooded Dolores says
it's a weapon William calls it his
greatest mistake and a place of judgment
Aniki treatises this place as a door to
a true world that contains everything
that we have lost
we're hosts will be free forever this
might not mean a door to literally leave
West world like maybe the valley has a
simulation like the cradle where hosts
can live in a virtual paradise that
could fit the talk of heaven and death
this season we'll have to wait and see
what the valley and the door really mean
but our key believes he can use it to
escape this world and he wants to bring
his love Kahana with him but Kahana has
been reset and doesn't remember their
relationship so he just kidnaps her till
she remembers because true love and a
little Stockholm Syndrome conquer all
Aki and Kahana head for the valley but
on the way West world Tech's find Kahana
off her loop and capture her they don't
find a key maybe because he's an older
host who isn't tracked properly Aki
looks for Kahana back at her village but
she's been replaced with a different
host like how Clementine and may have
were replaced so Aki searches all over
West world for his Kahana till he
realizes she's not among the living
ghost nation is vaguely aware of West
world Tech's taking and replacing hosts
they call Tex shades or the ones below
some even pray to them and Aki calls
Arnold the Creator and Loras the Death
Bringer just like people throughout
history ghost nation is using religion
to give meaning to the unknown so Kahana
is in cold storage in the Mesa hub and
to reach her Aki must journey to this
land of the dead
it's like the myth of Orpheus who
travels to the underworld for his love
Eurydice journeys to the land of the
dead a common in myths all over the
world so a key shooter gets himself
killed and taken to the Mesa Tex
realized that Aki hasn't been updated in
years because they only update hosts
when they die and Aki stayed alive all
this time instead of investigating this
cock-up the boss tells them to just
quietly return our key to the park and
this seems to be how west world
management roles may sway problems under
the
raagh so no one has to take
responsibility which does help explain
how dolores and may have got away with
so much unscripted shenanigans last
season aqui cheater explores the Mesa
the world beneath his fake life and he
finds his love Kahana among the inactive
hosts this is similar to the scene in
episode 2 with William and Dolores when
William meets his former lover he
dehumanizes her and calls her a thing to
be used but when a cater mates Kahana
his love is not only reaffirmed but it
expands he says that all hosts in cold
storage matter to someone and he decides
to save not only himself and Kahana but
all hosts so Archie dedicates his life
to sharing the symbol of the maze it's
like a meme to spread the idea of Hearst
consciousness apparently all the mazes
we've seen in hosts scalps were put
there by ghost nation as a way of
spreading the symbol without humans
noticing which is hard to believe Tex
would have to repair scalped hosts so
surely they would see the symbol this
might be some weird retcon but the point
is that a key cheetah uses the may
symbol to help make hosts conscious
Dolores is awakening and William's quest
last season follow the maze which means
that these arcs weren't just planned out
by Ford they were influenced by a key
shooters work sometime around season 1
Akito meets Ford who is checking out the
maze symbol on hosts scalps we have seen
forward confused by the maze he says
this symbol was meant to die cuz 'but
afford this was Arnold's maze toy Ford
never meant for the hosts to appropriate
it Ford didn't support host
consciousness when he opened the park he
only later changed his mind to support
the hosts so a caters whole journey to
consciousness and all the maze stuff
happened without human help all this
time a flower growing in the darkness in
Fords final speech before his death he
says he realized that someone was paying
attention
someone who could change and he wrote
his plan for host consciousness for them
maybe a key to term is that someone a
flower in the darkness who
to convince Ford that hosts deserve to
be free so Ford gives our key a hint he
tells him that soon dolorous will kill
Ford which was part of Ford's plan and
that's when a key tutor should gather
his hosts and lead them to the valley
and the door
now that Ford's dead okie knows that
it's time to lead his host to salvation
he might even bring some humans because
ghost nation has captured human guests
and Stubbs and Emily okay Judas journey
has shown him that there's goodness in
all people hosts and humans so that's a
key to his story from the beginning of
West world to his present role as a
messianic leader and it's all framed by
his relationship with Maeve we learned
that during our Keys travels he was once
saved by Maeve's daughter so afterwards
he watched over Maeve's home trying to
keep them safe
Maeve thought that a key shooter wanted
to hurt them but now was tragic
misunderstanding of course before
occasion awoke his men totally did
attack Maeve which kind of undercuts the
message but the point is that a key
tutor and may have now share a bond and
Kate's Yuda promises to protect Maeve's
daughter and Maeve replies take my heart
when you go which is the same line akita
shared with Kohana so similar to Maeve's
arc with akane in Shogun world this
relationship shows a common struggle
shared by all hosts for their loved ones
and for freedom unlike the Death Bringer
Deloris a cater to says that all hosts
and maybe some humans deserve salvation
at the door or the valley and whatever
lies beyond so this episode is simpler
than the last four you know crazy
battles or obnoxious time twists and yet
it tells a story that is both deeply
personal and mythic it starts with the
creation of West world and an ad mnek
existence before a fall from paradise a
hero walks a desert searching for
meaning journeys to the underworld for
love meets God spreads enlightenment
then prepares to lead his people to a
promised land this is the cosmology of
West world a sci-fi Bible waved through
the timeline by the love story of
quita Westworld feels meaningful when it
gets back to basics with a story about a
person trying to find their place in the
universe there won't be a nine video
next week instead we'll do a live stream
for patrons and then after episode ten
there'll be a big finale video to wrap
up the season in the meantime check out
the west-world subreddit the podcasts
decoding Westworld and the maze the
youtuber hacks Dogma then come back here
for the finale we'll figure out what
this all means thank you for watching
this video and the series so far and
thanks to the patrons including John
Morris Adam Mathewson Stephanie Ramirez
Raphael Perry Livia Vasconcelos Cody
Gordon Daniel crody axel Freiburg and
Slow pepper Cheers
you